>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> Anne McLean: Good afternoon.
It's my privilege and my
great pleasure to be talking
with the Juilliard
String Quartet today.
Joseph Lin, Ronald Copes, Roger
Tapping and Joel Krosnick.
Thank you so much
for being here today.
>> Joel Krosnick: Thank
you for having us.
>> Anne McLean: We are,
we have the privilege
of a unique perspective
on the Juilliard
because the library
has witnessed the birth
of this magnificent institution
and its growth and change
over many decades from the very
first performance here December
10th, 1948.
All the incarnations of
this extraordinary quartet
like a jewel with many
facets and I'm so pleased
that we're able to
present the quartet today
because this is their 70th
anniversary this season.
And amazingly they have
performed at the Library
of Congress for an astonishing
67 of those 70 years.
Seventy of the library's
90 years in the business
of being a concert
presenter, wow.
[ Applause ]
Oh we're very excited to present
you and I wanted to start
by saying that for
us at the library,
the many profound connections
between the Juilliard
and the library make this
especially meaningful.
Perhaps strongest of all is
a shared goal, a very strong
and enduring commitment
to the creation
and performance of new music.
It's great that they'll be
performing Elliott Carter's
First Quartet today along with
other masterworks by Schubert
and Beethoven and we'd like to
talk with you a little bit later
about your 50 year relationship
with Elliott Carter.
But to start with I wanted
to ask you about something
that is an example of how the
Juilliard continually has a
tremendous energy and excitement
that brings in new audiences.
And that is the new app
you have for Schubert's
"Death and The Maiden."
How did you come up with
that and when did you,
what's been the reaction so far?
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Joseph Lin: Well the idea
of the app was one initiated
by the Juilliard School
where we are in residents
in all teaching faculty.
In the Juilliard School
in various initiatives
to extend its reach to new
audiences and one of the ways
in which it's exploring
is through digital media.
And in collaboration
with a company based
in London called Touch
Press, which is a company
that creates many very
fine educational apps
for Apple products.
The Juilliard School saw an
opportunity to put itself
with the Juilliard Quartet
into the digital realm
in a very exciting new medium.
A medium that combines
many media
that would have been
separate in the past.
So certainly audio, but also
video and not only video,
but a kind of interactive
video full of possibilities.
In fact the possibilities
are endless and only limited
by the amount of memory that
you could reasonably expect a
product like this to take up
in order to be downloadable
for those using these devices.
I'll let some of my colleagues
speak about some of the features
of this app and the
experience of making it.
>> Joel Krosnick: Well I
mean part of the reason
for this app is to give not only
students of the sort of music
that we play, but audiences
a chance to hear and think
about music in different
ways than they would
if they were just sitting
there at a concert.
Among other things for example
you listen to a quartet play
and you hear the balances
and sound that we.
And highlighting of
materials that we have thought
about in preparing
the performance.
Now if you listen to this
app you can decide to dial
up the viola for example
and ask to hear the viola
at a somewhat more highlighted
version of the piece.
And follow the viola
part throughout or shift
and decide you want
to hear the 2nd violin
or the cello or the 1st violin.
In something that you
couldn't really do in public,
although depending upon
where you're sitting,
that may happen naturally
you know.
But the idea also is that you in
public probably don't really get
to follow and study the score
while you were doing it.
Well if you want in this medium
you can sit and follow the score
and a highlighted score you
can hear voiceovers if you wish
by the members of the
quartet on areas of the score
about which we are thinking.
It's possible also that various
historical information can also
be accessed while
you're listening
or when you're not listening,
just studying the piece.
So the idea was to give
both audience members
and non-musicians, as well as
musicians a chance to go further
into depth of a great masterwork
like "Death and The Maiden."
>> Roger Tapping: "Death
and The Maiden," is this on?
Can you hear me?
Yep, "Death and The Maiden"
seemed an ideal piece we just
happen to be playing
in that season,
but it's such an iconic work.
And happen to have the
extra bonus that it's based
on a beautiful song, "Death
and The Maiden" by Schubert.
And so also on this app you can
hear a beautiful performance
of the song.
So it's just a nice extra touch.
>> Ronald Copes: There is
in our commentary and also
in the analysis there's a book
that goes along with this,
electronic book that as part
of the app, which talks sort
of in depth about
Schubert's state of mind
when he was composing this.
And some of the historical
happenings that were
at that time and some of
the long standing traditions
or parts of the "Death and
The Maiden" myth if you will.
It's quite fascinating a book.
And there is a lot of attention
to the different elements
that we bring to it as
well as to the book,
to the different elements
that move through the music
and are insistent
through the music.
And I think one of the
experiences that I know people
who have seen this app
have is that they be start
to become aware of how
insistent these things are
and really listen for the
underlying dramatic elements
coming from these
repeated motives.
>> Anne McLean: That's
wonderful,
as I say this is example,
you have an incredible
energy throughout the years
that I've known the quartet
and each year there's
some new project.
I was thinking just
off the top of my head
of the wonderful cello and
piano new music festival
that you did Joel with Gilbert
Kalish [assumed spelling].
That was a whole introduction
to the contemporary music
for the instrument and
many recordings, dozens,
dozens and dozens
of world premieres.
And as we were saying
about Marlborough,
we're looking back this
year in the rearview mirror
for the library's
history for so many major
and meaningful associations.
And regarding of the founders
of Marlborough who came here,
wrote off Serfin
[assumed spelling]
and Adolf Bush [assumed
spelling] and so forth.
With the Juilliard we
look at you as family
and not only legendary
artists, but as family.
But in terms of the
work you've done here
if in there's been
incredible list of commissions,
the Martino Coolidge
Foundation Commission,
Richard Wernick [assumed
spelling],
Irving Fine [assumed spelling]
and dozens of premieres.
So maybe let's talk a little
bit about your memories
of new music here and how you
were, what are you doing today
that is exciting for the next
coming 90 years, 70 years?
[ Laughter ]
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Joel Krosnick:
Well we played a work
of a young American composer
Jesse Jones last year
and we carried that
through the year.
Next season the quartet
will premiere work
by the great Mario Davidovsky
and the quartet continues to,
is not a new music group.
And we continue to play
classics and the great classic
and romantic literature.
And we play the music of
our time where we have to go
through as we have with Richard
Wernick's 9th Quartet this
season and understand somehow
what he's put on the page
and make it come
out in our voices
of recreation of his creation.
And we continue to do
that and we discovered
that when we give it the care,
the same care we
would give Mozart,
Hyde and Beethoven
and everything else.
That it turns around
and informs us perhaps
about curiosities we might have
about what's on the page in Hyde
and Beethoven and Mozart.
And so it works both ways,
to play the works of our time
with the care that one
would devote to classics.
And to perhaps in so
doing, play the classics
as though they were new.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Anne McLean: I remember Joel
Smirnoff saying that in regard
to new music one element of the
Juilliard's deep involvement
with this world of contemporary
music is that several
of your members over the years
have been serious composers
and I hadn't thought of that.
He mentioned that
Robert Mann had studied
with Stephen Volpe
[assumed spelling].
Also Klaus Adams
[assumed spelling] studied
with Volpe [assumed spelling]
and Sam Roads [assumed
spelling] is a,
didn't you just do his quintet?
What was that like?
>> Joel Krosnick: We just
did several of his quintets.
He studied with Roger
Sessions [assumed spelling]
and Milton Babbitt
[assumed spelling].
And the quintet is of
absolutely beautiful work.
[ Background Sounds ]
Sounding like a young man
who very much admired
Sessions [assumed spelling]
and Babbitt [assumed
spelling], but at the same time,
at the same time very much what
became Sam's voice as an artist.
And again was quite
an involvement.
It's a very hard piece,
it's a [inaudible].
>> Roger Tapping: I think
there's been a rule, am I right,
in the quartet's history
that you don't play works
of the members as composers,
but Sam was retiring
and so he had us
at a loophole here.
And it was an opportunity for
me as the person who was going
to succeed him as we
are a way to come in
and have that sort of overlap.
And do some concerts to play as
the other viola in his quintet,
which was a fantastic
experience for me.
And it's one of the hardest
things I've ever played,
but I loved it.
>> Ronald Copes: My experience
in working on Sam's piece
and playing and performing
it was most of the time
when you talk about a composer
and you say there's nobody else
who could've written that.
It's because that voice
is so well established
through their compositions.
And my reaction to Sam's quintet
was nobody else could've written
that even though I had not ever
heard another work of Sam's,
which so often heard his
voice playing the viola.
And so there was
something very idiosyncratic
and at wonderfully Sam.
>> Anne McLean: Wonderful,
you know I've,
I came across a comment by Tim
Page [assumed spelling] saying
that it's hard to think
of another quartet
that takes a listener so deeply
inside a chosen composition.
Wonderful thing to say
and I know that's something
you inculcate in your students.
And Joel you've talking
very interestingly
about this experience about
watching your students come
into a composition and
discovering it and so on.
And I wondered if
you guys could talk
about how we could
experience the Carter today
with all the wealth
of experience you have
with Mr. Carter's work.
You take us inside it.
>> Joel Krosnick: Well
one of things I and we,
we're very empathetic
with listeners hearing
something for the first time.
And we regard ourselves as
having the responsibility to be
as clear and as communicative
about the elements
of the work we would
like you to hear.
And I guess I wish
you would listen today
and let the piece be what it
is to you as it's going by.
And recognize what
you can recognize
and just let it go by you.
And be there with every moment
of the piece as it goes by.
For you to try to sit there and
figure out the brilliant mind
of Elliott Carter
as it's going by.
I don't know, I can't do that
and I've played a whole
lot of pieces of his.
But you can allow the music
to go by and to realize
that there were things in
a New York composer's life
at that moment young man who
then chose to spend a year
in the Sonoran Desert
writing a work.
And certain of those things
help you reach in to the piece,
but he intends to communicate
with us and through us to you.
And I would just allow
it to happen naturally.
>> Anne McLean: You know
there's so many things
that we could talk about and
we really could do this on,
in a long oral history session.
We should do that sometime, but
to move toward something else
that has a great connection
between the Juilliard
and the library are the
instruments sitting here
in the cases.
And the many years of experience
you have had with them
and I wanted to ask you all
what does the experience
of playing a magnificent
instrument do for you
in performance and even in your
understanding of a work perhaps?
>> Joel Krosnick: Well I mean
among other things I guess I
probably played the cello more
than anyone else played any
of the other instruments and the
Castelbarco cello is a basso.
It's a basso de Keizai
[assumed spelling] so called
and that is a cello
that was designed
with a slightly larger
bottom part of the instrument
to produce sounds from middle C
down to the two octaves below.
Sort of if you wish as
a continuo instrument,
as a lower instrument.
Perhaps as the lower
instrument of a quartet
or in this case the
lower instrument
of a trio sonata or a cantata.
It has a fantastic
lower register.
I often wondered
while I was playing it
and I loved that cello.
I mean that cello was
really a fantastic cello
and I often wondered when I
played pieces where I was high
up on the cello, whether Strad
would've been a little surprised
to see me meandering up to
the top of this instrument.
That was actually made for
its lower register and yet all
of it sounds really fantastic.
And I was from the first time
I came some weeks before I
actually began to
play it and the staff
of the library kindly
provided me a room.
And the cello and I spent
the day practicing it
and playing scales on it.
And playing various
pieces on it.
And it was love at first touch
and I loved that instrument.
And it's very particularly
suited for playing in a quartet
because of the lower register
and it's hard to describe,
but I played it for many many
years and loved it always.
>> Anne McLean: You
know I've, I saw a quote
from you were describing
a performance
that I actually remember very
well at the Smitten Quartet
and you said to a
reviewer afterwards
that the Castelbarco
almost played by itself.
And this with you,
you were just,
the reviewer described this
as a molten performance
by Joel Krosnick and you said
that afterwards you looked
at the cello and
said, "Who are you?"
I know Bobby Mann used to say
that the Strads [assumed
spelling] were like race horses.
That you had to, you couldn't
just expect to tame them.
You had to be careful
and get to know them.
And so for they could
run away with you
and ruin your performance
if you didn't really
know what you were doing.
>> Ronald Copes: I think in
one way the experience is
that they aren't completely
under your will as it were.
There's an element of a great
instrument which suggests things
to you and so it's not just
that they do exactly
what you're thinking.
They do maybe something even a
little bit better, I mean it's,
but they're a really great
instrument does suggest a lot
of things.
>> Anne McLean: And do
following up on that,
Joel we had a young person here
recently who said he was trying
out this cello and you had
told him about the cello.
I'm trying to think of the
person now, it'll come to me
in a second, but he
said that you told him
to try the instrument
and see what he thought.
And that afterwards you
heard him play in Wile Hall
and you went up to him and said,
"You see what a great
instrument can teach you."
And that was a fascinating
comment to me
as you were saying Ron
you learned so much
from the instruments themselves.
How does that work
in your teaching?
Do you, are you able to
work with rare instruments
at Juilliard as well sometimes?
>>
>> Joel Krosnick: Well there
are some very fine instruments
in the Juilliard collection.
I remember one particularly
significant experience
where I was trying to illustrate
something for a student
of mine who's a wonderful
wonderful brilliant cellist
and played with a
lovely smooth open sound
and it was very beautiful.
And for some reason I think I
had my cello as being my cello
that I own was being repaired
and I had another instrument.
And I wanted him to try that
instrument, which he did
and so part of the lesson I
was playing his instrument.
And I couldn't get anything
out of that instrument.
You know and he'd been
producing this gorgeous sound.
And I'd been teaching the
fellow for several years
and I never had any idea
he had an instrument
that was difficult to play.
And I was open in my admiration
I said, "Young, I had no idea.
My god this is."
Oh it's very hard.
You know well, but
you learn things
from playing an instrument.
And he had a sound
in his ear and sound
which he learned physically
to produce something
that was analogous to
what he was hearing.
And so one transcends
the instrument,
but one learns from it.
And playing that Strad cello
would teach you something
about the, about how to love
the lower part of an instrument
or how you know you couldn't
push that cello exactly.
You had to wait for it and
it was really wonderful.
And the students at Juilliard
who have an opportunity
to play something
beautiful, that's the idea
that they will learn from an
instrument that will lead them
in the direction of sounds that
they might not have imagined.
>> Ronald Copes: On the same
sort of a flip side of that,
not every instrument or
there is no instrument
that is really right for
everyone and to illustrate
that perhaps the most
famous instrument
in the collection here
is the Betts Stradivari.
And Bobby Mann did not like
playing that instrument at all
and used one of the
other instruments.
Whereas Joel Smirnoff loved
playing it and I think some
of it has to do with the
different styles that we have
of playing, the different
ways that we produce sound.
The different mounts of weight
and bow speed that we use
and certain instruments are,
will emphasize one or the other.
And I don't, you probably knew
that very often I didn't use one
of the Strads, but rather
used the Kreisler Del Gesu
which is also in the collection
because it produces
sound very differently
and it was more suited
to the way I was used
to producing sound.
>> Anne McLean: You know we have
so many interesting musical
comments to think about,
about what you've done
here at Straus [phonetic]
as we talk about and so forth.
And I'm just sitting here
thinking how the work
that Juilliard Quartet has done
at the library is not
only a significant part
of our history, but
of music history.
In terms of all the things
that have been done here.
For example you brought
the Bartok Quartets here
when that was still a new
thing to play them in a group,
you know, a cycle of them.
And you early on did premiere
Vialobocean [assumed spelling]
Hiostero [assumed
spelling] Quartets
when no one really
knew those and so on.
And a lot of very
unusual works large.
We had the Strad
Quartet, sorry, octet.
We did a whole octet evening
with the Concord String Quartet.
That was cool.
We had the instruments from
the Smithsonian's collection
with ours, but I was thinking
too it might be interesting
to see what some of your
personal history moments
might be.
For example from me
and my colleague Michelle Glenf
[assumed spelling] who's sitting
in the audience, we watched
you watch the World Series
in the back room.
Any fun things like that
that pop up in your mind?
[ Background Sounds ]
I'd have to say that that was,
it's interesting to
think about that.
We have this tiny studio in the
back behind the concert hall
and we sometimes have
used it for rehearsals.
And I understand that the
Budapest Quartet, then you think
of is these very austere and
you know extraordinary gentlemen
from Central Europe and Russia
and so forth, that they too used
to tune in to the World Series.
So what makes the Juilliard,
now that you, it's interesting
for me to have observed
the incarnations
of the Juilliard
as I've been here.
And my former boss John Newsom
[assumed spelling] knew a much
earlier incarnation and so you
are experiencing this again.
You have recently and
now you will again.
We had Astrid Schween
here recently
and it was very interesting hear
her talking about her career.
And her looking forward
to joining the Juilliard
and the mentorship that she's
been receiving from the school.
And from the quartet
and from you Joel.
But I wanted to ask you
what is your definition
of the Juilliard Quartet now?
[ Background Sounds ]
>> Joel Krosnick: You know
that over the 70 years the
quartet has probably changed
in sound in different
ways you know.
In a purposeful specific way
we've never discussed it.
We deal phrase by
phrase, style by style.
We talk about all the things
significantly involved
in playing whether it's
the Carter First Quartet
or the Quartets out to Schubert
or the 135 Beethoven done today.
And all the different
things that one talks about
and reaches for and
thinks about.
No doubt the priorities of
those things have changed
over the years, but I
can't remember any time
where we said well okay
we're going to change this.
This is not you know the way
we're going to do it any longer.
And when people ask
us how has it changed?
To tell you the truth, we've
got the worst seat in the house.
We're inside, we're inside
the workings of Beethoven
and Schubert and Carter.
And using our instruments and
our minds and our imaginations
to do what we believe in.
And we haven't changed
on purpose.
>> Joseph Lin: You just
mentioned that the activities
of the quartet have not
only been significant
to the library's history, but
also to the history of music.
What has taken place over the
last 70 years and I don't think
at any point along the way the
quartet set out to do anything
that would be significant
historically in the moment
of doing any of these things.
Of playing all the Bartok's,
of bringing Ginastera [assumed
spelling] et cetera, et cetera.
But it's a spirit
of as Joel says,
doing what is important to us.
What we care about.
Often in the face of
contemporary trends,
but we feeling that
there's some value to it.
And at a certain risk that we
don't know what will happen
when we premiere the work of
a 35 year old, as was the case
with Jesse Jones'
piece a few years ago.
But it in a way the value,
part of the value certainly is
in that willingness
to take the risk
and in some cases it
may prove well worth it.
In other cases, maybe not as
much, but the spirit remains.
And maybe that's more important
than whether that you know
in retrospect gets viewed
as a historical moment
or a particularly significant
in the larger scheme,
but it's that moment
by moment attitude.
>> Roger Tapping: And I guess in
as much as there is a continuity
over it all the years,
which continued
to make the Juilliard String
Quartet, it is just the sort
of basic underlying ethos of
four people coming together.
Extremely open to each
other's thoughts and passions
and opinions with a level
of trust that the idea's
that somebody's going
to come up with,
which may well not be what
you thought of yourself,
are really worth considering.
And so there's this sort
of openness to each other
and there's, that leads
to a sense of exploration
which keeps the music alive.
And which keeps you very engaged
in the process of rehearsing
and very much in the
process of performing.
And I think that's probably been
a constant which leads to a sort
of passion and curiosity
and seriousness.
>> Ronald Copes: I
think one of the things
that is quite conscious in the
quartet's evolution in a way is
that we do, we want
it to evolve.
So that at every
step along the way
when there's a personnel change,
we very consciously
are interested not only
in someone whose ethos embraces
that or whose ideas embrace
that ethos, but also
someone who's going
to bring different ideas and
different ways of thinking
about things into the mix.
So there's a conscious
desire to feel
like what we're doing is
letting the quartet move
in slightly different
directions and
yet remain with that same ethos.
>> Anne McLean: Wonderful to
hear your answers on this.
Any, I know that we need
to let them get ready
to perform and so on.
Just want to say, maybe
we should open up for,
can you take couple
questions, are you okay with?
Okay great, anyone have
a particular question?
Yeah.
[ Background Sounds ]
>> I just wanted to ask if
anyone, if any of the current,
any of the members here played
the broken string concert
at the National Academy of
Sciences and what was that like?
I mean I think three strings
broke or did four strings break?
>> Ronald Copes: Broken Strings.
>> Roger Tapping:
Oh Broken Strings.
Do you remember an event?
>> Anne McLean: Oh that's right,
I remember that there
was [multiple speakers].
>> Roger Tapping: Where
lots of strings broken.
>> Anne McLean: An
occasion when you were,
the quartet was playing
at the National Academy
of Sciences and.
>> Joel Krosnick: Yes.
>> Anne McLean: Incredibly
one after the other.
>> Joel Krosnick: It was the 3rd
Carter Quartet and I don't know
who went first, but I think
Mr. Mann broke his string.
And so in about the 60th
measure or something,
it we'd been playing
for about a minute or so
and so we started again.
He went off and changed his
string and we started again.
And then I think I was
next and I broke a string.
And we started to
laugh, we went off stage
and I think we got a
little further that time.
And then unbelievably
I heard to my left,
Mr. [inaudible] his string snap.
>> Yeah.
>> Joel Krosnick: This not
possible and I remember it well.
And remember Mr. Mann
turning to the audiences
and you will know the
opening a hundred bars
of Elliott Carter's 3rd
Quartet better than any audience
in history [laughter].
>> Roger Tapping: I remember
once being very grateful
for a broken string
as a very young man
at a music festival I
played my first performance
of Bartok's 3rd Quartet,
which is pretty scary the first
several times you play it.
And it had started
to go a little wrong
and then somebody's
string broke.
So we had the chance
to start again
and it was much better
the second time.
It led me to the
slightly bad thought
that maybe we should
have a little invention,
some little sort of thing
where you could automatically
break a string
with a little lever for a finger
[inaudible], strategically.
>> There's an app for that now.
>> Roger Tapping: Well yeah.
>> Ronald Copes: You
mean you don't use yours?
>> Anne McLean: Anyone
else have a question?
No, well thank you so much.
Uncompromising integrity,
the Juilliard Quartet,
thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of The Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.